[Musik]
stellt euch mal vor ihr steigt nur um
bei gordon ramsay zu essen ins flugzeug
fliegt in ein anderes land steigt aus
dem flugzeug aus guckt euch die stadt
ein check ins hotel ein und geht dann
einen abendessen für nichts anderes
genau das haben wir gemacht wir haben
uns die wunderschöne stadt london
angeschaut und hatten gehofft dass wir
einen mindestens genauso wunderschönes
abendessen genießen können bei gordon
ramsay himself der einzig wahre gordon
ramsay der im internet alle leute klein
macht wie gut koch dieser mann wirklich
wie gut wird in seinem restaurant
gekocht wir waren bei gordon ramsay bar
grill und haben selbst abgecheckt
[Musik]
wir sind jeden moment da gordon ramsay
bar and grill 1 von 15 restaurants die
gordon ramsay in london hat und ich sage
euch eigentlich leute ich hab so hohe
erwartungen das muss kaiser ich meine
wir sind dafür hierher geflogen das ist
ein anderes die laufen ja warum es noch
ein werk von john ramsay da reicht
für 2
wir gucken uns nicht mal die karte an
die hier drüben ist sondern wir gehen
einfach ein schöner ein
die karte bekommt die ente was würdest
du sagen was ist eigentlich so es ist
eine mischung aus alten deine und fans
der as ticket
ich würde dir da bin ich direkt schon
verbraucht aber aid hat reise kann ich
heute eigentlich nicht beurteilen kann
ich eigentlich nicht macht die meisten
haben oder nicht und da sind wir sind
nicht in deutschland wir sind in london
am mikro pole und ich glaube preisniveau
im vergleich zur band ist auch noch mal
deutlich höhere camps zu wenig der
aktion ja ich sag nur schmerzen ein
bisschen wenn man als vorspeise
und ihrer moretti italienisches 14 von
zehn haben noch ein bisschen was ich
stelle mich immer so ein bisschen an ich
fühle mich nicht so wohl immer in den
restaurants zu reden und so aber jetzt
kann ich einfach machen
der allergien
deutschland noch nie gefragt wurden
außenstände könntest ja ich war zu
langsam du warst du weißt du was mir
gerade so aufgefallen
das sieht gut aus ist nicht nur schön
aus finde ich guck mal das musst du ja
schon so hinlegen das sind damit das
überhaupt so erst mal hunger hoher
qualität testen
panisch hier alles der salat frisch
feiert die idee dass das nur so aus
diesen salatherzen ist doch schön immer
den kranz unten an dem stil was
stripping sehr gut fühle das ist so
ballack weiter
häufig kleine vorspeise früh so wie sie
im detail nicht man hat jetzt wirkstoff
auf mehr
also noch neues
tief in die tasche greifen und ich haben
uns danach gegessen deswegen steak zu
schnaps hält zusammen ist trotzdem
überall ölfund geiles dreßen wiesen
lasagne player tessin mail adresse
wechseln mit dem maßstab den wir an
gewinnen kann weil die vorspeise schon
kreativ frisch hamburg macht mehr zu
essen das machen wir
beide ein halbes hähnchen und ich sehe
zuallererst ja wahnsinn dass sich zehn
von zehn aber die waren sehr mutig weil
kurzes schwarz stellenweise ist kann er
jetzt wohl kaum verbrannt schmecken
das geil aus das ist glaube ich das
okay so was probieren wir zuerst ich
weiß es nicht positiv wird sagen dass
schicken ja weil ich meine das ist schon
so ein laden da wird gegrillt da geht
viel glaube ich um einfach so die kunst
am wie sich das schneidet und wäscht
schneidet sich um normal guy helfen
schön glasig so komme jetzt rein verzehr
erstmal kurz drüber nachdenken für
diesen moment
im bereich vom hotel gebiet haben
unzählige formulare ausgefüllt das muss
jetzt in sache wert sein es muss sinn
ergeben dass wir hier kommen so ein
querschnitt
für die mannschaft sein kann
die 2
meist geht es von der textur er ist vom
mund geführt das ist als hätten die
wassertiere
kurzfristiger ich kann doch nicht sein
also du musst mögen das ist eine kleine
schärfe aber auch mal mehr ohne guckt
euch diese dunkle sich flüssige
schülerklassen ist also das hähnchen
kann ich jetzt und hier so sagen ist das
praxisteam was ich hier gesessen
restaurant wird sich erstmal und was man
noch die menschen sagen muss der kasten
der restaurantkritiker meint er dass er
und das gerne bestellten guten
restaurants weil das so oft verpackte
und hier ist alles
verwüstet auch mir jetzt dahin hätte ich
weiß nicht was ich sagen soll henkel
fleisch ist kein schwimm- und wilma hier
lieber auf brust die brust musste zuvor
das nachkochen technik noch mal gemacht
du kannst einfach durchschneiden weil am
rhein neckar
was passiert
also
mache ich nach norden zeitungs wie diese
marinade geht ich hasse euch mal ein
bisschen zusammen ja heftig die würzig
großzügiger wo ich finde es auch ernst
ich finde es auch nicht mehr viel was
ich dafür bezahlt haben 14 wie geht
diese brust und alles was hier so ein
bisschen dunkel ist alles was hier so
dunkel aussieht ist einfach verrückt ich
habe mich auch gefragt wenn ich hierher
gekommen nach london durch hätte
imbisskette als vorspeise das hätte die
truppe fast weise das ist nicht ganz neu
aber wie piri piri schicken gewesen was
ich wunderschön finde es hingeht
erwartungen der hohen erwartungen und
diese erwartungen nicht nur erfüllt
sondern sagt du übertroffen es wird
schwach ich bräuchte jetzt wirklich
nichts mehr nach dieser sehr sehr gute
vorspeise und dem exzellenten hähnchen
aber ich will noch vor weihnachten
bisher teilt und dann ist es auch rap
für heute mit schlafengehen freundin die
könige alter schlafen die könige nach
diesem abend essen
oder einfach schon mal freuen
es ist gar kein ersatz für so ein
schokolade kriegt dann dachte ich auch
aber wie sieht das schon wieder aus als
der damals
das ist weniger ein stück kuchen als
noch so punkt auch vorher ein bisschen
winterspeck oben was saftiges und der
sohn nach dem krieg sieger care komplett
es ist nur dann seine tat bittere note
es aber nicht so die wirkmechanismen ist
nächstes möchte ja das ist gar nicht so
dass da nicht das vielleicht so 10% süß
und freeman vor das eis ist auch sehr
schön
treten werden 20 jahre lang lebte sie
erlebte die härtesten weg diese
formation erste schock ist so cremig
jürgen süß ist der dezenten bisher
ich schlaf weil man danach darüber aber
es war wirklich ein erlebnis und ich sag
dir ehrlich dafür hat sie es
also allein dafür hat es sich schon
gelohnt nach london zu fliegen aber wir
waren ja nicht nur bei bayern griff
sondern am nächsten tag auch noch bei
burger und pizza das würde dazu kommt
noch ich werde mich aber jetzt nochmal
hinsetzen reflektieren und eine
detaillierte bewertung schreiben für
unseren besuch wie schmeckt das essen
von dem mann der so gerne schimpft und
so berühmt ist sehr sehr gut egal ob
hummersalat piri piri schicken oder
chocolate tat alles war grandios das
ambiente war angenehm und man gewöhnt
sich sogar an den fernseher der inmitten
des raumes hängt und sport überträgt der
kellner und das gesamte personal haben
überzeugt die offene küche stiege das
selbstbewusstsein wieder dass dieses
restaurant kerne haben darf hier wird
gut und ehrlich gekocht man fühlt sich
einfach wohl und hat eine gute zeit mit
gutem essen fünf sterne so er hat's
gesehen leute das war meine bewertung
war wirklich wirklich gut da sage ich
nicht nur weil ich den ganzen aufwand
auf mich genommen habe
weiter so ich glaube das interessiert
die nicht weil er ist übertrieben
reichert 400 millionen dollar und
überhaupt nicht was ich zu sagen ein
match ist